greetings from podcast Ville the church
is brought to you by Ridge wallet calm
listen tremendous if the ridge is a
minimalist front pocket wallet that
helps you reevaluate your everyday carry
launched by a father-and-son team and
funded by Kickstarter in 2013 the ridge
is a front pocket wallet designed to let
you ditch your bulky wallet it's slim
RFID blocking and lifetime guaranteed do
me a favor right now go to Ridge wallet
comm slash church and use code Church
and get 10% off today today I'm gonna
get your 10% off cuz I'm in the mood
like that go to Ridge wallet calm right
now
use code Church number to the savages of
the supplement world on it the other day
I went up to row gives to do to
podcasting emails coconut chocolate
protein [ __ ] little num nums that
they're out of there's a reason why they
sold out you know why let me tell you
they're [ __ ] delicious that's what
I've been living on the Omega for teens
on the road I even take one on the plane
with me on them I sleep apnoea plain I
replace whatever piece of [ __ ] snack
they give me with omega 14 [ __ ]
protein bar listen I live on that how
for brain I live on the shroom tech
anyway what I'm trying to tell you is
you want to give you a head together go
to an ER calm right now and press in
church boom and get the party started
they'll deliver it right the house 10%
off on the arm just pray it's pressed
Church on the way out and you help me
out Yelp on that you help everybody
alright kick this [ __ ] melee and I
said I said now I finally know what that
means I never knew what that meant and
suddenly it came to the I gonna give you
every inch of my love hand I'm gonna
give you dick [ __ ] eyeballs they were
the most sexual innuendo band yeah that
you have like you know everything their
blues just makes you wanna [ __ ] when you
were a kid this this song made you wanna
[ __ ] get double your [ __ ] frustrated
what [ __ ] and a whole lot of love
nobody wants to suck my dick
like Digg and what's up my friend ha
always a pleasure to see ya the
mouthpiece is still working
I still uses its effectiveness [ __ ]
we'll talk about that later but now
about a month ago I see something people
bleeding from the [ __ ] head you know
you open up the Facebook and you see
some guy bleeding and it's bad knuckles
and I'm like oh we're going back to
Charles Bronson yeah hard times buddy
I'm going Jesus Christ and all the
sudden to you and I speaking on the
phone and you tell me you just got
appointed the president what is it WV
kff the world bare-knuckle fighting
federation and where are they out of its
Casper Wyoming we're located in Chicago
but Casper Wyoming over Wyoming is right
now I believe one of the only states
that legalized it
bare-knuckle so all the fights have to
be in Casper yes that's crazy
yeah Aaron Wyoming don't call me in
Casper thousands of times oh yeah yeah
so anywhere in the state away home and
you could bare knucle it that's it and
you know I think well you know it's
frowned upon right a lot of people they
think I was gonna be blood all the
players and people CTE but actually I I
did a Google search because before I
said yes to them I said let me give me
give me a day let me think about this
and I start googling and I could not
find a test that said otherwise if you
google is bare-knuckle boxing safe for
them boxing every every test will say
yes and the reason is that like hard
times we were just talking about hard
times you remember the bold guy who
would catch all the punches on the
forehead right he was leaning over the
whole time and that's what happens
you're gonna break your hand like in the
eighteen hundreds when boxing was
bare-knuckle in England they they
realized that if somebody's defended his
title then anybody broke his hand in the
process he couldn't defend his title for
the next six months so the promoter goes
like man we gotta figure something out
now we all notice about with mixed
martial arts we went through this but a
lot of people still out there they
believe that the glove is invented to
protect the head but it's not it's to
protect the hand that's why they
invented it because people broke their
hands what is bad about that is that
normally bare-knuckle fighters they hit
about 40 50 percent of their power
hitting the head because they do not
want to break their hands so they focus
more on the body and they hit less heart
to the head so CTE wise it's actually
safer
boxing boxing you have a boxing glove
you can just hit as hard as you can and
trust me if you hit bare-knuckle
something and you hit the boxing glove
something the power the impact is going
to be the same only with the bear but
with the glove it's going to be much
harder because you're not going to break
your hand now of course it will
penetrate more with a bare fist but
that's on the face has nothing to do
with it yes you're going to get
lacerations that's the thing we're going
to have a problem with but but that's
about it
we have plastic surgeons we didn't have
normal doctors we didn't take normal
doctors we have plastic surgeons at the
event two of them so if that somebody
gets get cut you know we have the
plastic surgeon to just stitch them up
and make sure that it almost doesn't
show oh my god starting the frame right
what do you think as a fight I would if
you were still fighting would that be
something you'd be like that sounds like
okay I truly believe because I just did
another interview and they said you
think this is more like the guys whoever
may who didn't fight for a long time and
they want to come back now and they'd
want to do bare-knuckle boxing and I
said well if bare-knuckle boxing would
have there been there at the time when
anybody started I think a lot of those
guys would have actually chosen takedown
or knuckle boxing no takedowns no
nothing you can't cleans though you can
hold and you can do uppercut almost like
dirty boxing you can do that as well so
yeah once once we get over that hurdle
once people see it once you start
watching bare-knuckle boxing in England
it's huge inhalants right now and
actually Julianne Lane you know I want
to bang that guy you know from the
Ultimate Fighter he went to England he
beat the bare-knuckle champion there who
was 18 fights undefeated and we haven't
won the card as well so I'm super stoked
about the scar it's going to be great
and I think we're going to see fighters
using different strategies you know it's
different than MMA it's a different
business than MMA the punches penetrates
easier because there's no gloves and
amazed tiny gloves it's also penetrates
easy about boxing of course bigger
gloves and Thai boxing you see so it's
harder to penetrate now yeah every punch
is probably gonna slip through but
you're gonna have to pick your shots
because if you punch me and I just lean
over and hit the top of my head it's
night-night to the end you know you're
gonna break your hand and that's why
they go 40% to the head you know it's
funny when we start the conversation
this is why I love you to death because
right away you started with CTE yep
right away that seemed my
that was your biggest concern you didn't
look at money you wanted to you really
care about you know I don't want to do
something that that I'm going to feel
bad about later in life you know if I
thought what if some people people start
dying and you know because the first
thing and now what you knew this
somebody told me no but it's actually
safer than boxing but you know you hear
that but you don't really know so that's
why I said let me Google a little bit
let me play around with this tonight and
let's see what happens and then you find
out that's it it is indeed better than
c-tec de Bie it's better for the for the
player for the fighter for the boxer in
this case and it's saying it's like
there's a ref in the ring during the
whole everything it's everything is very
classy we go we're gonna have a very
classy show we have the ring goes with
night gowns we get you know Jimmy Lennon
jr. is the ringer the ringer now so we
got can you rise it back with me you
know we got a whole really great team we
have for Frank Belmonte who did the
Pegman mayweather show I mean we have
the production top not stop now and is
it is the only life or can I watch it
online on TV or something well we're
going to start online or fight TV that's
for the the prelims fights we have four
of them at five maybe because you know
how it goes before the fight everybody
DS sake and he cannot didn't approve and
it's a it's a freaking nightmare now I
know what it really is you know it's a
lot of work but then after that you know
when people see the production and they
say hey man well I would love to check
it 29.95 we kept it very cheap also if
you want do the high-definition of
course like ten bucks more I believe
okay cool so now how many one of the
rules for this now how many rounds just
five rounds of two minutes which you can
play around with once you do with title
fight you can increase the rounds it
flew around two minutes per round two
minutes per round five rounds I think
for an MMA fighter we have a lot of MMA
fighters you also have a few Pro boxers
a woman pro boxer and a guy pro boxer
also the guy don't fight so Julian Lane
actually is a pro boxer who wants to try
it out and now we finally can figure out
if but you know all the boxers say oh we
beat these MMA guys easy in boxing well
now's your chance it may be a
bare-knuckle boxing let's come over to
our side and see if you actually can do
that so you think that fighters to go to
different strategies head to him that's
pretty brilliant that you thought all
this out yeah no yeah we just talked
about that the movie hard times with
Bronson that's that's what the guy does
that's how everybody breaks their hand
in that movie and it's true you know III
told the story that I was sparring after
seven years I didn't spar it took one
more fight in 2006 and I was sparring
with a guy and he first he asked me do
you want to spar so now my reflexes are
not back yet I just started you know two
weeks ago he says oh that's okay I said
oh no I'm not saying that for you for me
I'm saying that for you because normally
when I give you a head kick and I see
that you're not blocking I can redirect
the head cake and I'm not gonna hit you
but now I don't have that reflex it's
been a long time ago
so let me get into it is - no I don't
mind to say okay that's good then we
fight
I said don't throw that crazy overhand
that you have that's what I told him and
the first point she threw it was the
crazy over and right in my neck so I
stopped and I looked at him I said okay
you know you do that again I'm gonna
hurt your hand and he started laughing
and we started boxing and sure enough he
threw it again only thing I did was lean
over
he hit the top of my head he was on the
ground and that was with a boxing glove
I said I told you I'm gonna hurt your
hand you know and that's why I as the
bouncer also you know when is when I was
a bouncer and guys they talk to you yeah
yeah and did you know they turn away you
know they're gonna sucker punch that's
that was the moment I was waiting for
because if they turn away if I see one
movement only thing I would do is lean
over because they hit the top of your
head and they're not gonna break the top
of your head oh no no the bones in the
hand much tinier than the thick skull
let's go yeah something like I'm just
[ __ ] just [ __ ] blown away right
now I shouldn't smoke that pot and
another great thing about this is
distance I always talk about this since
I quit boxers right if you if you
squeeze the whole time you can't box
right because you're draining yourself
so what happens you make a fist at the
end of your punch that's where you start
squeezing right the last let's say this
this space you start squeezing the hand
with this if you lean over so if the
target is here and you want to hit it
but the head is still relaxed you and
suddenly I lean over I'm closing the
distance so not only you're gonna hit my
head full power of the top of my head
but your hand is not fully squeezed yet
because you do that only at the end of
your part so if I suddenly meet your
fist
halfway down by bringing my head forward
yeah you're gonna snap your hand for
sure
and what about the jaw like is it only
on top of the head like no no you're the
jaw that's good you know you can hit the
jaw of course yeah that but then people
go like where you can break the jaw yeah
okay
I believe so that it can break easier I
I do believe that because it will be
bone on bone come on guys have an MMA
glove and what about this what Thai
boxing you can shin kick somebody in the
face you can knee them in the face you
can elbow him in the face they're all
unprotected much harder weapons than a
punch right Annie a foot I mean it's
longer on its way to travel it's a
heavier object and it has more time to
develop speed and power and that's why
it's way more so Shin kick from from
crow cop in the face you think that's
healthy right and now you're talking
about a little tender hand that's gonna
hit a skull come on guys you know the
smart guys they hit 40 50 percent to the
here allowed to need somewhere in the
face no no but I'm forgetting yours but
in other sports that may you can do that
in the face I've never seen that no no I
have a really great knockout to hit I
can show you and I drilled some buddies
the interface Oh like literally grab him
by the hair and then I need him as hard
as I could in the face you see but
that's an ensign on protecting me you
know so people that's allowed a food a
shin and knee and an elbow is allowed
but suddenly hand is not allowed you see
so if you start breaking it down you're
gonna realize why actually he is right
and what I always say don't believe me
just google it you know I say of course
because I'm the president of the company
people can overhead of course he says
that google it see it yourself this CTE
has become the attic topic yep
you know I saw this thing down having
made junkie about opioids and do UFC
already oh yeah it's so bad it's
everywhere and I started thinking about
the NFL wow you know four years you're a
player you gotta do what you gotta do
you getting six million a year and every
year there's a new college all-american
that's coming out that's challenging
your job yep and you play hurt and you
shoot pain pills and you shoot pain
[ __ ] solvents and yep you know then
you see these guys years late and they
can't walk throw Campbell yeah you
crumbled your liver you crumble
everything is the worst stuff you know
II noticed you know I hadn't uh
to my last fight all my injuries that I
retired for in the very first place I
didn't fight for seven years I thought I
was completely in the clear everything
went perfectly I felt like a maniac I
mean literally in a month I will
everybody was telling me that I was
training to do it you got a new career
this is insane I mean you're flying
through everything I say hit this wall
right and then BOOM if first injury came
back and that came back and that came
back and that came back and you know and
so and then some you know so I fought I
couldn't kick higher than low kicks
because people said because I stopped
the guy with low kicks they said why
didn't kick him in the head I could kick
higher than Loki because I've taught all
my groin you know I had a rip out and my
knees they were completely shot I mean
everything that went wrong at 10:00 and
night is in both arms I could only
shadowbox I couldn't even hit the bag
anymore with my arms I was in so much
pain so what starts it started there
with the simple Norco I remember taking
one and a half Norco on the day of the
fight at 10:00 a.m. in the morning
because it said you know at least ten
eight hours you don't have to take
anything because it can affect you
mentally and I figured you know my fight
is gonna be around nine o'clock you know
I'm the main event not the Komen
actually I thought was and then then
it's out of my system you know but you
know I remember the next day taking
again and after the fight you know you
were in pain and slowly and then I
remember a time that I wrote a nine and
number nine with a with a pencil you
know the my wife uses his makeup I put
it on the on the mirror I remember
putting in a left corner the number nine
because I took nine pills a day and I
was not going to pass nine pills a day
well those nine pills they became twelve
bills at the time at one time four times
a day five times a day so now I'm paying
in 48 pills today now the doctor says
dude this is so bad for you it's it's
all the time and while you're taking
because okay there's less tylenol and in
the Norco dananana vicodin but it's
still really bad you're going to have to
switch the oxycontin
okay dork you know idiot that I am and
then an oxycontin oxycontin is just
that's pharmaceutical heroin you know
and then you realize and I had this
problem that I went to I believe it was
Ohio or something and I measured every
older pill out and I had a five hour
delay I ran out of pills and let me tell
you that's when I realized I'm addicted
you know I was on the plane shaking I
couldn't eat swanning cold sweats
goosebumps all over the place and I go I
gotta kick this stuff and then I start
kicking it then I did it the wrong way
because of the wrong way I did it with
the suboxone and suboxone is kinda the
rich man's methadone right that you get
from the doctor but what you should do
officially you should build that off
what you can use a two weeks and after
two weeks you should stop that my doctor
said no no it's good it was still works
for the pain and you only can take less
so if you start with a whole pill you
can literally go to two quarters you can
go to a half you can actually build off
instead of going up all the time with
the pain pill so I figured you know I
believe the doctor I do that but then I
was on for that for three years and you
should Google what happens to people who
are on that for three years because once
I start hearing I heard dr. oz dr. Drew
was talking about it on the radio and I
go what and then I start googling and
finally after three years like googling
what I'm taking it the idiot you know
and it's so bad it got in my bones it
took me 11 days to kick that my supposed
to take it for two weeks for two weeks
because if you win it over two weeks you
don't have any side effects it over
three years I did it for three years so
it gets into your bones and it gets the
double-vision sweating heart rate is
like 95 in bet you can't be you can't go
to the restroom again I mean I wrote a
whole list of side effects than it had
and so I got to stop this crap so then I
finally I stopped it I tried cold turkey
didn't work you know because my daughter
I was five days in I was like freaking
out it's really hard like people say
that it's it's way harder to kick that
actually oxycontin by itself it's very
hard to kick the suboxone so then I my
daughter had a party that weekend I say
okay I'm gonna have to take it again I
mean otherwise there's no way it can
help you to my wife yet 70 kids coming
so I took it again felt good right away
again
and then I said okay now I'm gonna smart
I'm gonna build it down literally go to
a quarter to an afront and a third from
that quarter and hey you know it's
slowly but surely down then once every
day a little tiny crime under your
tongue and then slowly okay then I
stopped and then 11 days those eleven
days do the hell you know what my
testosterone level was they've never
seen anything it was five so not five
hundred it's one two three four five the
doctor showed it to another doctor and
they're both freaking out they said what
how can you come out of a how you get
out of bed I said I'm really I don't
want to go out of that but I have to I
just force myself drinking coffee and
once I'm going I'm going he said
women have 60 you have five here people
you know people go don't go to work
anymore did they stay in bed it's
amazing that you still come out of it
how's your sex drive I said that's gone
you know and that's the moment that I
stopped doing all that crap and once
that comes back oh man you're like
freaking Superman no like the the III
explained it like the the bad guy you
know Michael Shannon who played the bad
guy from Krypton right he came here and
he took his helmet off and then here
everything all the people all the sounds
he heard because he was not used to that
that's exactly when he came over that
stuff like shades had to wear everything
this would be way too bright light for
me I mean I was crazy that your your
senses are so out of control because
they're not stomped away anymore maybe
that's the box suboxone so how does it
compare to like methadone it's the same
stuff you know it's yeah so it's a it's
just what they call the rigid that's
what that's how I heard on dr. Dewey
says the rich man's methadone and I go
What did he say and then I came home
started googling that's when I realized
I should have stopped it with two weeks
so yeah I have so many people who email
me and I have a whole piece now written
out that I literally can copy and paste
because you do that five times you go
like I should save this because more
people are going to ask me the same
question so now I have it all written
out that I only have to copy and paste
and right away if somebody has a problem
and now now fortunately we have a CBD
right if you use good CBD with a little
tiny bit like 0.3 percent or 0.5 percent
THC you really helps you to calm down
like a pain pill if you take three pain
pills a day let's say if you take CBD
you only have to take one because it
will enhance it so it's an easier way to
build up a lot of these facilities where
you get detox are actually using CBD
right now to bring it down marijuana as
well found by the way it's funny cuz CBD
does calm me down yeah somebody told me
you'd be taking edible and taking this
out of control I have emergency CBD in
my drawer like in case you take another
bowl or something to CBD calms you down
oh really
others I know at night for a fact that
the nights that I put seedbead under my
tongue thanks about an hour yeah but
I'll fall asleep really good it's nice
you're relaxed she takes a bomb
yeah you know again I get the 1% you
know what I do I I eat something I take
the CBD I wait 10 minutes and just eat
one or two slices of bread and then I
will go into your system right away it's
a better way of doing it because
sometimes inedible can show up two hours
later right but if you eat with it's
like 10 minutes later it'll pretty much
within 10-15 minutes it's on yeah I
don't need elbows no more but I like the
CBD without it they say you have to have
a little bit of THC renovated to
activate you up for it to take it to
where the pain is and stuff so I get a
small percentage now because I don't
know it was starting to get me sick the
edibles oh I believe it I can't do
animals if I do edibles you know it
affects me the next day you know I'd
literally use but people don't believe I
- I buy a creme a whiff a pan I can
literally do two and a half or three
months with that people got there's no
way I literally go about four seconds I
put it and not even till it starts
blinking and I'm gone and I'd only do it
once a day so but if I would do during
the day if I'm at a party or something
and I don't want to drink and I take a
little zip just not to drink and then at
night I want to go to sleep I need more
but if I don't do that only one I only
need one time a day like three or second
for second drug that's it and I sleep
perfect I'm feeling great no headache no
nothing it's the best all the pain is
gone
it's a it's really an amazing product
smoke weed no no I I do I do a night
also like I take the flower I do that
but also I very little amounts I do for
me I only want to calm down and I tell
myself don't you don't need to go go out
of control just calm yourself down and
feel my legs my legs I have this great
feeling and some of my friends have it
too but most have not like it starts
glowing
it's literally when I and it's such a
good feeling like it might my legs hurt
a lot but at night and I only do it once
I'm in bed so you won't see me walking
around the house and no I lay in bed
that's when I take my little zip I lay
down and literally I think 25 minutes
I'm out feeling great I don't forget
years ago this had to be 10 11 years ago
when people are talking about the
benefits in marijuana
I got a toothache over the holidays I
needed a root canal over the holidays
and nobody was open and I didn't have
vicodin you know I was taking pain pills
whatever the [ __ ] Advil and one night
the pain woke me up but I go let me see
if there's marijuana [ __ ] once when I
smoked a bunch of pot I smoked a joint
like ain't no more the assault and it
was so weird that I got so high I
started writing that I forgot about the
pain yep and I said this this really
works and not my wife is on the fence
after 18 years of being with her she
went to a kids party Saturday night at
the martial arts school yeah she took
mercy to watch a movie over there and
the owner and the wife and a bunch of
the moms were went outside and went to
smoke and that she told me she was you
know the guy smokes like oh come on
that guy's [ __ ] straight isn't out
she goes no he Bruce Lee smoke man he
comes having pain and he got off the
pain pills and started smoking blunts
now this pain went away so he's been
smoking blunts at night and I thought so
my wife is considering she should be at
night after mercy falls asleep
listen it's we know this you know and
your listeners probably noticed as well
it's just labeled a drug because of
alcohol came out at the time before the
government labeled it as a drug it has
always been medicine I have a priest
that I know I'm a Catholic and and and
and he said no absolutely you can use it
if he uses for your pain yeah if you're
all day long start smoking lay on bed
you don't do anything non-productive
yeah do you not just don't live a
productive life they wouldn't be okay
with that but it did God invented that
plan for a reason and it is to help
people for just the government they
realized wait a minute we got alcohol
now we can text that it's very hard to
text the weed though because people can
grow themselves oh let's make it a drug
and they labeled it a drug and boom it's
funny on the website now on the
government all the things like gateway
drug and all that stuff that they wrote
they all have that's all off now because
now the truth came out now they have to
literally take that off because it's not
true you want to hear a gauge where drug
alcohol now it goes the gauge where drug
I know that all the crap
real bad stuff I did you know and it's
not never to other people but to myself
right
it starts with alcohol because that
lowers your level you go oh yeah that's
actually a smarter thing to do I can do
right now which you would so it was
survey what did you drink what you do
first smoke a joint a drink a bottle of
Boone's Farm and I guarantee it's 70/30
yeah 70/30 because that's what I did I
drank Boone's Farm first but I knew at
the age of three four or five I didn't
like drinking I drank a bottle of red
wine with a three-foot ha ha my mom with
my mom on the bar so to put me to sleep
she dipped my [ __ ] pacifier in
blackberry brandy call it a sugar cube
my mother was a savage yeah yeah in
Holland they put a little like that
honor on a sugar coupe and I gave it to
the kid so what you say so I [ __ ] I
saw her drinking this red wine Italian
and she put it on top of the
refrigerator I don't remember this no
wait for her to go to sleep
but I drank the bottle of wine like Vito
Corleone II she woke up three hours
later I was missing she called the cops
the cops found me in the closet [ __ ]
diarrhea you oh yeah and I never drank
again so drinking was not on my agenda
well I was like seven I saw these kids
smoking when that I borrowed them now
cigarette do you remember years ago the
cigarettes called now now they came red
green and whatever I might took two hits
of it and in the bathroom of my house
there was like an ironing board and the
kid in the bathroom and one of those
things that you scrubbed with Mia I
remember I took I was making believe I
was [ __ ] my mother was in the
kitchen anyway I was smoking the
cigarette the bathroom like at 7:00 do
it this a great I started getting dizzy
as [ __ ] oh yeah and I put the cigarette
on top of a piece of wood and I left it
there oh yeah she's like what the [ __ ]
was smoking like I have no idea I'm
puking [ __ ] so I was away from all that
yeah but the first thing I did even
though I was exposed to marijuana was
drink yeah I drank for one I totally
agree with me yeah no I have to drinking
is you know always I'm a happy guy
by doing so at least I have that and I
want to have fun with everybody but it's
just you know being drunk morning around
the house it's just not a good thing and
that that thankfully I got out of my
system really farewell really fast no
people know all the stories right
there's been a lot of crazy stories but
you know that was drinking fighting
keeps you in line that's the great thing
about fighting you know you do after a
fight you know you go to three days
crazy and then you have to train again
for the next fight I mean I fought in
Japan from 93 let's say to 97 for four
years I fought at thirty fights that's a
lot of fights you know you fight its
first year for a year
oh yeah no I fought that first year of
nine fights I think you know I had a
really high schedule that was MMA that
was ever made but at least it was in
pancreas you know sure we have the shoes
with the shin protection in the open
hand to the face a closed fist to the
body you know but you know that it was
just a great way for me to keep myself
in the in check it's very hard also from
the fighters when they stop fighting
because you don't have that high anymore
like if you knock somebody out
you know it's it's like a hole-in-one
you know the forgo of I assume you know
you're there people go nuts it's a
feeling that you start really enjoying
and if they suddenly be taken away you
start trying to replace that with
something and most of the time with
fighters there's drugs or booze you know
like a Pat Miletich is very smart about
it he just picked another crazy thing up
he's chasing tornadoes he says because I
know if I don't do not do not do that
it's probably going to be drinking or
something like that you know so he uses
that to still to get that same high back
you know with me at the time I was
drinking that's why actually I took the
last fight in 2006 because I was I was
drinking pretty heavy and I looked at my
wife I say you know what I was going I'm
telling take the fight because if I take
the fights I can't drink anymore I quit
drinking so that's what I did and from
that moment on it was all good now I
don't you know I got a little out of
hand like a couple of weeks ago and it
was the first time I think I was drunk
in over a year you know you know box
room huh every once in a while my wife
goes to bed early I leave it's I don't
tell nobody but now you're telling it on
the radio oh you had some fights
attendin I'm I can't go to bed at 10:00
tonight
hey I just can't you know I can't end
night time the nightmare I'll be up at
4:00 yeah yeah yeah and I'll get high
and make a meal and then I'm back
sleeping at 6:00 and I'll mix kickboxing
I won't wake up till 11:00
yeah they'll ruin my whole [ __ ] day
so some nights I'll have those they give
me three deals anxiety pills oh and I'll
take him to the comedy store I'll put
him in my jean pocket and if I sit in
the back I'm high and I struggle a
little anxiety pop it before I go on
stage that's my thing I get really bad
anxiety when I go to the comedy store
I don't know why yeah it's myself yeah
so weird so as I'm walking up the stairs
I looked I made sure that I see oxygen
like I have to see an opening yeah those
days like I don't know I don't freak out
on planes yeah and I've gotten on planes
on tuta thousand edibles a tinea see oh
yeah like in the third hour you just
[ __ ] that's found like I've never
freaked out I've never freaked out like
I keep it under control
but this sunlights I come home I take
that anxiety throughout the college tour
and it's a [ __ ] anxiety pill because
when my friends give me the stat is an
extinct yeah oh yeah compared to that
now like it's six lows yeah like six of
those little ones is one of those holes
oh yeah yeah so I pop all those and some
nights I got home and I don't really
feel the anxiety pill oh I drank a half
iron again oh yeah then it goes and then
I hate to I hit that pipe one time and I
sit at the desk I pull out beautiful
ones by Prince goddamn [ __ ] foxhole
with debt and I still remember one night
I drank the whole beer or like one shot
like I thought it was Johnny Bananas and
I drank the whole beer and I'll never
forget that I had to walk into the
bedroom feeling the wall like that's how
drunk I get like I get [ __ ] lit from
wondering Oh a couple weeks ago on
JetBlue I thought it was Johnny Bananas
phonetic and I got the red wine oh yeah
I just get red one is very good feet I
know but I've never I never drink 155 is
it I've been drinking more red wine
lately like officer no no no and it's
not fancy no this was the first red wine
I've had maybe a year these two spin in
snare and smell it and no one on the
menu a mint and mint they have a certain
red wine yes and I drank the red wine oh
my good [ __ ] that is so crazy I
[ __ ] passed out for now but I don't
like drinking on a plane because it
dehydrates you and if I worked out sad
they might fly Sunday now I'm gonna be
really sore yep so I usually drink on
the way outbound I usually drink
outbound without drinking but not all
the time not at all and I fly mint as
much as I can
yeah yeah as much as I can I mean I just
went to West Palm Beach but they flatter
for my Liddell meant got it
I'm going New York Wednesday got it I
got it
Emily oh yeah yeah I'm addicted we went
to Boston God no it's nice oh I love
myth that there's nothing it's the best
I get that single seat and I live like a
[ __ ] doctor in there yeah you could
jerk off you know that if you hangover
its frowned upon right if you do that
what's that hangover when it's like I
was slug the plane is frowned upon but
you can do it to you one day I was
sitting up take the right that I can
bang one up and nobody would know it was
like 5:00 in the morning I got on there
and some hot chick I felt like asking
that like I went back to my cocaine days
I would fly on coke
oh that get freaky oh I just sit next to
a [ __ ] now how are you doing dry mouth
oh yeah you know in the eighties - now
flying his change oh yeah yeah in the
80s it was more of a party yeah people
got on a plane the back of the plane
smoke smoke so everybody said the back
was boozing big yeah making noises buy
them a drink
I used to go down planes where I was
part of a group all of a sudden part of
a group we need a virgin at that time
remember they have their own bar virgin
you know in first class
I remember
I should have had that at the time they
had it when I was a kid
United had a bar in the middle of the
plane they had like a view one coach
it's that shitty bathroom they had a bar
with a bar and a big bowl of her
quaaludes and first class with stands
upstairs first class was upstairs yeah
yeah there was an airline that went from
Newark to LA and Newark to England and
the newer thing with why they know for a
fact they had a pig that would lap once
mouthing first class no way as a guy
would pull a piano real [ __ ] but I won
on a plane in 87 cigars in 87 86 I would
go back east and I'm gonna pick up coke
and bring it back to Colorado and that
would be [ __ ] out bosphorus yeah and
one day I went up to the middle I did my
bump they'd like people you could walk
around the plane I shall write to the
bartender I wonder that middle bathroom
I did a tremendous blast I come out of
the bathroom at the neck twits the whole
thing those days they used to drink gin
and tonic it's where the Shila do is I
was gone 87 that's how I opened up and
give me a beer and keep them other
families on these flights to kids drugs
did yeah I got a plane dominated people
smoking cigarettes we people drinking
you could see who was flying to Vegas
for the hooker huh she had two tits out
flying was completely different
well that flew to San Francisco I banged
my wife right now what yeah I gave her a
stabbing her dick on honeymoon night
world in those days fines were why the
planes weren't packed
a blanket over you nothing I've got
about I picked her up gave it to her
right in the middle machine oh yeah Wow
I go up to the middle of this bar I'm
called back to the guild
they got the bartender's got like a
black towel like it's like a velvet
thing and he says to me what can I get
you the pieces fell out Oh Rock the
black guy fell and me and him both
looked at it and I'll never forget I
looked at him and I was at the top of
the plane like the chip of paint just
wiped it all even though I was a good
night and don't I didn't know I believe
like I didn't know what it was yeah yeah
yeah it was it was just it was different
times it's a different time yeah were
planes being like landed early all the
time and people arrested for being gone
can stuff no no listen listen like now
people go in saying in 1984 in the heat
of cocaine an airline called people's
Express decided that they were gonna do
something that nobody else was gonna do
they were gonna schedule a flight every
hour on the hour from Newark for $49 but
after midnight it was twenty nine
dollars that means that me and bas
Rutten could be in New York City at a
bar they [ __ ] [ __ ] as crazy as me and
bas Rutten were talking [ __ ] and Moffat
said hey I got a cousin in Miami that
gets ounces for 800 and I would look at
bars and say bonds I have 11 in my
pocket what do you got mom's are here
for let's go to Miami boss would go to
the pay phone put three dollars of
quarters in because in those days you
put a quarter in down the number and
then the quarter will come back out say
two dollars and 85 cents and you had a
quarters in 35 more cents please yeah 35
more sense five more cents please
maintain all since you shut the [ __ ] up
and your phone call will go through and
you would call your cousin picked up my
mom and you pick up that answer well
well when you come in tomorrow Tuesday
right night didn't have
you didn't have to call people's
expression just showed up and if they
had room fee on the plane you got a I'm
never forget good going down there one
Friday night like Southwest at like 4:00
in the morning and if there was a
hundred and eighty people in that plane
I swear to god Basra 961 coke dr. oh I
believe it and we all got on that plane
and it just everybody was John because
that was the thing yeah I was I go to
Atlantic City it was an hour away yeah
what are you doing tomorrow I hope to
meet my mother [ __ ] huh come on one way
same price coming back yeah and and and
you know if you come same day back you
don't have a jet lag nothing's bothering
you you can go hoops it's actually
really great in here
this was a long and they always they did
a late they did no work that way for $69
$69 and they didn't know what to England
they banged you out on the plane and
charge you for the pillow you got bangs
for the meal
you want so Noah to the dollar 50 that's
how they got on the spirit okay that's
how they had but you pay with a credit
card on the point yeah
that's why I came in I'd go on there
with somebody's credit card even though
the person I go see Joe the Baker up
from the Bronx for a nickel credit card
and I just go on in or in the middle try
to get yeah they would note that you
were gone those costs they didn't have
no computer in those days yeah yeah
so they put on a pad so I be in there
yeah Jamal a drink I'm the whole hour
drink yeah I'm smoking cigarettes town
moving the Mafia yeah and also the check
comes they would charge you the $49 for
the flight and then anything else you
took the blanket three beers six sodas
the luncheonette kit which was like
great pieces of cheese salami and they
would bang you out and then by the time
you got off the plane you owed to 300
you should have flown American yeah
single American for 279 first class yeah
but you had a good time but you had a
good time yeah and there's no stress no
nothing
nowadays that's completely different
right no there's no they watch on a
plane now
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I will see people
having a good time on a play coach is
they give flying awash wouldst look at
coach when you get up in mints look at
coaches like they're flying oh Sh
oh yeah yeah nobody smile and
everybody's got their head down we'll
have something stupid that plane could
crack nobody's smiling nobody's in the
hole laughing no and what no one tries
to do to the first-class they tried to
go to the restroom to get sent back to
get sega peter no no no your your rest
who is there in the back are you gonna
make before I flew in those days I would
take no books no paper and I would make
Bendel's and I'd put like a quarter gram
and like six or seven bindles and I'd
eventually do three of them but there
were tips yeah yeah lying people in
those days I would give cocaine out like
a tip every time you can't use that
bathroom what do you mean okay good
quarter gram in their pocket that's a
quarter gram when you land to get you
the way you need to go to pick up to the
[ __ ] load yeah that's a diamond in
the rough I used to every time I got
coke and I had like an ounce I'd make
like six or seven little bundles to go
away like [ __ ] Bobby you didn't get
arrested
no nobody nobody arrested you you know
who was doing they like it for knives
and gods yeah they don't look for drugs
with somebody's hand they gave you like
a look like how do you know if I looking
in you when I knew you out the night
before so right off the bat I'll never
forget
look at that I'll never forget being at
a bar and the cops got surrounded like
who in there [ __ ] around and they
were looking for us we put that was a
day we threw a guileless no Bank and the
cops came and I'll never forget walking
past the cops
I remember having like maybe like an
eight ball on me and told my baby it can
be down though and putting like $50
worth of coke on the dollar bill and
when I walked out the top see yelled and
began against the wall but you're my
friend and you're a cop and if I could
get to him with if I had to get to you
with this 20 in my hand because this was
the juice that would make me get through
and I'll never forget the cops going you
turn against the wall it's like gonna
turning late and in Austin he just took
me and go these are righties
ha ha ha everybody knew that was a
tipping that was a that was you know but
Bitcoin yeah yeah that was my big [ __ ]
that was mine Bitcoin he called coin you
put a 20 in a bindle for somebody you
made that [ __ ] day dog wow you made
that day any time I got a little bit of
a shipment anything like an ounce or
something I had always given a couple of
packages and people oh I had a guy out
he got its old sneakers at Levy's
Sporting Goods I had decided I repair
sneaky when I was a kid I'm gonna walk
in there five with a rock the size he
hadn't give it to him
he'd been drinking doubles all day he
was one of those guys I got to this
morning there's a tent and the whole day
he'd be sipping [ __ ] I forget what his
land is God blesses so he died years ago
he was like 50 at the time in 1982 I
would drop the grandma off on him and go
back I was laying and he'd be taking
care customers all [ __ ] up all [ __ ]
up my hell yeah life is it was a ladder
are so funny you can't tell ya I tipped
so many people with cocaine those days
Lee it was funny people loved him when
you gave somebody a little Rokit coke or
I would get the bottles and take half of
it out and leave half of it in there was
just like yes of a grab you give that to
somebody with a little sport on it don't
suck your dick they said actors state
that it was just common that they went
to their trailer and there would be Coke
for them for the actors right that like
the movie company would literally just
arrange that there is coke if you hear
those stories from the 70s with these
people all these actors what they were
doing it's insanity I heard in Miami
that they were doing it at restaurants I
could look in the face of lighty and
tell you I never I never saw that my
life yeah I saw it in 84 years later in
New York City at clubs it was wide open
so we were at the Comedy Store and we
were in the main room we'd be in a booth
there would be a mirror somewhere with
khokana in that booth and nobody was
accepted yeah was it but it's a club
yeah it's a dance club you know
saying that's people dancing or
everybody knew we're gonna lay these
bathroom and it's not net but I never
went to a restaurant where they I heard
stories where the waitstaff would bring
it for you I know I never saw that I
never said that either yeah it was crazy
times though and you started doing drugs
in Holland in Holland yeah all the way
back yeah that's crazy
everybody goes all the way out there
yeah yeah it's uh you know every I think
a lot of these guys you go through
through it you know and then you know I
think that the way we did it if you do
it when you're young and then you know
you realize okay you find out it's not
good it's always better I say that I
have friends of mine and I knew some
guys who didn't do anything until they
were 45 and they're drinking a glass of
wine or something suddenly and they
really enjoy it and since they never had
the bad experience boom they're hooked
to it and it's the same with coke or
pain pills or whatever it is they would
then they would get addicted I said
we're at an age we did everything but
it's past we know it's not going to go
anywhere you know you're standing a
little bit stronger in your feet that's
what I think you know I think it's okay
to experiment there's some things I
never did like acid I would never do I
would you know I had some good oh yeah
but I'm afraid I'm the guy who the worm
start growing out of his arms I'm gonna
stab him while with the knife you know
like III think I'm gonna fly I can fly
by the way I never got that you know why
don't they try it out first on the spot
if they can fly you know and then jump
off the building right yeah you know
it's not working maybe I shouldn't do
this because because it's not working
you know but ya know crazy times crazy
times it was just but what me normally
it was pretty much for a long time
alcohol that was that was my choice of
thing never weed because in Holland yeah
it's always been legal
to my knowledge when I was there but it
slowed me down and I'm always this upper
County guy that's why I'm only doing it
you know to go to sleep or if I go to a
party and there's a lot of drinking
going on and I want to eat and I say
I'll take a little zip and I'm feeling
perfect I'm nice and relaxed I can still
formulate sentences because of I'm
stoned I can't that's why I don't want
to do it during the day and it affects
my memory you know so if you have to
memorize pieces and things like that and
there's no way you can do it I have
other friends of mine who excel when
they use it
they actually get
better and they can memorize better and
to do everything better with me is the
opposite so that's you know for me it's
good that it happened like that because
it keeps me in line so to say for me I
cannot think of myself not smoking it is
the last of my teddy bears yep
okay everybody has a teddy bear yep it
is the last thing from that life that I
have left I enjoy it
it clums me down I like getting high in
mine when I get back from the Comedy
Store with different like I have to buy
two types of weed yeah like I'll smoke
this all day but then it make like this
and no no they both in business I'm
gonna fight yeah me too I only hear like
a song smoke that at night to take that
calmly edge off yeah yeah that won't
keep you up till 2:00 in the morning I
get a notebook out I put music on and
I'm writing as I'm listening to my set
whatever I'm saying just to slow me down
you know marijuana has always slowed me
down I would never I don't want to do
either or do I have any desire to do it
no I mean I don't ever want to speed up
no I always wanted something to slow me
down when I wake up in the morning my
cup of coffee I look at my early morning
emails I talk to my daughter I talk to
my wife and then there's a point in time
where I know I have to eat I have no
appetite so I go in the back and zip -
dipped yep and boom the appetite opens
up no he could eat I don't have to eat
like a gorilla like to eat two eggs a
piece of wheat toast I'm done no but
that gets that appetite dog mm-hmm I
want that appetite in the morning not
that appetite my blood sugar drops in
the afternoon and I'll eat much later at
night and that my hunger oh triple so if
I eat early like I can't do intermittent
fasting yeah yeah yeah yeah no I I get
up because if not it catches up to me
and I hate trip one night you know well
it's a good thing to be there and
they're like everything else you know if
you would have kept on drinking you
probably wouldn't have been here anymore
if you kept doing all the other crap you
probably wouldn't have been there
anymore
it's literally weed that saved your life
pretty much I like it keeps me a list
the thought of saying the word sober
yeah would drive me crazy and it drives
a lot of people crazy that's why the
volume of relapsing that there is after
relapsing several times you'll realize I
don't like the word sober yep and I
don't like the word diet yeah those two
words kill people yeah those two words
kill people I like the word lifestyle
yep this is the lifestyle that I could
lead you know in saying like if you look
at it it takes pressure off your mind
without you thinking of it I am NOT on a
diet I just have to acknowledge that I
have to eat a little better yeah yeah
you could go to [ __ ] uh what's the
sandwich place Jersey my Jersey Mike's
and you could have a turkey and
provolone for six points yeah you don't
need the chips yep you know you do put
mayonnaise on it it's not gonna kill you
yeah you just don't need the chips can
you throw yourself a nun eating the
chips and drink a diet coke because
you're out yeah but the rest of the time
it's war you know little things it's a
lifestyle
yeah I'm not a diet once you kill me
kill yourself with that word diet you're
done I do not want you to be sober I
want you to be happy
those are two different [ __ ] don't play
I need you for 90 days to walk around
with a frown and every time I Drive
players Lankershim I see black people
and I want to do crack listen you're
killing yourself to live yeah kind of
deal with yourself in 85 95 I got a bad
deal with myself I cut a deal with
myself I was gonna go all-in on comedy I
was gonna dedicate myself to comedy but
at the same time I wasn't gonna keep
fighting this cocaine war yeah if it if
I do it I do it no more doing it beat
myself up yeah and lying to myself daddy
this is the last time no boss
I'm happy you're here this is the last
yeah I'm gonna do this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
poisoning two hours later I heard that
broken record yeah but then you hit
yourself in the face you the whole time
and it was a broken record of myself to
other people so I said forget it
I am accepting your problem that I have
I accept it I don't want to go overboard
I knew that I could get one package and
go to bed at night and jerk off till I
passed out and maybe do a xanax and fall
asleep I was hip with that you know I
really was I was very cuz I knew if I
looked at it like I'm trying to get so
but what it never does it's not gonna
work it's not gonna and I think that's I
hate the word sober and I hate the word
diet yeah that's what to me show you
don't drink anymore I never say that you
know what when I go to breakfast just
don't get the potatoes yeah eat the
bread put a little tiny butter on the
bread eat the two eggs and eat two
pieces of bacon
just don't eat the potatoes you see I I
ate an enormous amount of potatoes that
I love them I'm taking yeah but III
blend them because they take so much
with vegetables I put it in a blender
like a pan and I literally drink it and
the meat or the fish or whatever I make
that I bake and make really good for
myself and the rest this doesn't even
have salt on it I just drank it for pure
nutrition and pure clean everything
clean like my first till like 6 o'clock
at night and it's even if my wife cooks
it's I'm still eating clean with her but
sometimes when you go out to dinner
that's when I repeat a pizza or doing
this but normally doing today I'm trying
to live very clean now you know I
noticed that I I'm completely different
person if I eat correct
you know if I eat the vegetables and
then I do that with the meat I'm feeling
like a maniac you know you also when you
get older you start getting bloated at
all that's when you eat too much bread
and stuff like that it's such a BS and
as soon as you start switching to
vegetables and you do just one if you
have a bloating feeling just do one week
I would use to make used to make a big
pan of vegetables all vegetables in
there and potatoes everything and I
would eat the whole day it would just
eat that you did it for one week all
your bloating is gone then you can eat
bread here and there but once you start
eating bread three times a day again it
will start again you know what helped
really helped me because I tried it for
my arm see this all see it's all gone
the lower part because of the neck
surgeries it's atrophied here so what
they told me is BP Seif 157 it's a
peptide and what it is is officially
it's a gut enzyme and what they thought
in the beginning because if you have for
instance yet cancer they would see that
all that BP see was around to cancer so
they thought oh it's causing the cancer
we have to watch out for the but then
they real
it's actually it's trying to get rid of
the cancer that's what it's doing so
they've got enzyme so they figured out
that it repairs everything in the body
so now you can get a peptide which is
leaves it's not even on the the fighters
can use it and it will make you heal
your tendons everything it will heal
faster so I start trying that and I put
it right here in the biceps to see if I
can reactivate my biceps with the
muscles you know but it didn't work but
what it did do was thinking complete I
lost my the bloating I don't have it
anymore and it's got to be the BP see
because that's literally got enzyme and
those are the enzymes that you start
losing when you get older and that's why
you stop bloating so it's a perfect
little thing it's cheap it's legal
working you go you know yeah I have an
address for that because peptides online
is a very dangerous thing because you a
lot of the guys they just sell you
powder right though it comes from China
you have no clue I have a company 99.9%
pure 100% so I'll send you that Atlas it
works really well you drink of a water
or something like that no no what you do
it's you've got to shoot it yeah yeah
like a like a like a little how you
called the diabetes needles you know do
you think you're right no no you just
put it in the fat of your body in your
stomach and or when you have an injury
you do is closest to the injury as
possible that's why I did it in the
biceps but then I realized you know I'm
just gonna do it here and yourself every
day yeah but it's a little tiny
I'll stick with [ __ ] yoga oh actually
actually actually you can put it also in
your mouth you pour it in with a needle
so you know exactly how much take which
is a little tiny bit a put onto your
tongue you leave it there for 60 seconds
that's gonna go yeah at friends like
that too I got a coupon it's in fact
they're gonna make an appointment for
tomorrow I forced myself to go to
acupuncture but the needles for drugs I
in fact the hell did doctor a blood test
and the tetanus shot and I'm gonna void
him like [ __ ] an HIV victim an 85
I'm in 85 maybe we'll talk to people's
let it tell you they had AIDS oh you
were just [ __ ] run the other way and
they would sneeze in front of you think
you're getting it if you have open
wounds and you're close to them you know
there was all these crazy stories right
now you weren't where were you an 85
with the whole weights camera and an
aunt and how bad was it no no we only
heard the stories from here in America
you know that story that they woke up in
the morning and a hundred mirror was
written welcome to the world of H you
know you would have sex with the
prostitute and she would be HIV positive
and then she would write on the mirror
in the morning when she would leave
welcome to the HIV Club or something
that was this do you don't even hear
that heard about that or you see because
that was apparently happening in America
that they were doing that was some just
weird thing that'd be heard in Holland
but for the rest in Holland yeah I
didn't really notice it you're a lot on
the radio when people are afraid of it
and they thought with blood it can pass
on with blood or rubbing against each
other even if it spit they thought in
the beginning right drinking from the
same glass all that stuff yeah people
got paranoid you know but then you
realize that it's not you know still you
know it's logic is its and it's a
natural thing to do you know if I don't
have to drink from the same bottle from
somebody who's very sick I'm not gonna
do it it doesn't matter if it's eighths
or if he's got a cold if he's got a cold
I'm not gonna drink from the same bottle
is he because why would you take that
risk wheezing are you gonna get the call
so it works pretty much with everything
but it was not as big as a scare we just
heard the crazy horror stories from
America that wasn't on it
well once Rock Hudson went public yeah
that was many people started getting
sick and stuff like that I remove like
people were [ __ ] scared people were
really scared that that thing that's
going on in Jersey with the kids like
where all the kids died in that hospital
all sudden there was like an epidemic
but HIV was out there but those first
couple years I got a lot well I got
locked up in 88
there was an HIV one unit oh and I
became friends with one of the guys and
we talked and he broke it down for me I
asked him and then after that I felt
safe and I hung on the HIV unit for nine
months I don't have HIV
yeah so they were right I hung on that
unit I use the same utensils they used
that scare can you imagine if I were to
dump bare knucle bark
in that time people would have been
really afraid because with babble
drunken boxing of course you're gonna
get cut right so there's gonna be blood
CTE why is it safe for you but cutting
you know that's I think people would
have freaked out I think everybody needs
to be test is 100% I still then you're
gonna freak out especially at that time
when it was at the at the height that
everybody was scared of it
that [ __ ] I still can't get over that
we're back to everything makes a full
circle made us well back the [ __ ]
knuckle hitting each other in their
heads were [ __ ] our hands how cool is
that though think about it you know we
were talking about a hard time she had
Johnny Hendrix Brendan Ward's I mean
these guys are the main event Johnny
Hendrix we all know he's got this crazy
big left hand but I bet you he's he's
not gonna throw it for power because he
knows he understands the rules now if
Brandon Ward just leans in like I said
and he hit the top of the head he's
gonna break his hand if you didn't focus
on his right hand he's gonna have a
problem you see so now you're going to
be more strategical you're gonna have to
although they also hit all the meaty
parts they hit the forearms the
shoulders you know the body they focus
on that and the power shots go 40 50
percent to the head because they you
know yeah you're gonna get cut but
that's it and by the way with the
cutting we have plastic surgeons
actually we hired instead of normal
doctor we said no we're going to pay a
little bit more we have plastic surgeons
so if you get cut which will probably
will help happen you go to the bag you
have a plastic surgeon there who's gonna
stitch you up it's gonna make it a nice
little cut and yeah you know as well as
I do one the weight class it's still the
same shave the same yeah 135 170
yeah I think even with boxing the boxing
weight class is right so they have even
more weight classes so that's exactly
the same the tapes the hint sorry is you
have to tape minimum an inch behind your
knuckles so you can't have any cannot
have any tape on the knuckles but
strategy wise you know I think it's it's
going to be a whole different ball game
especially for the MMA fighters now also
we have some professional boxers on
there so that's cool now we got an MMA
fighter actually Julian Lane he is
fighting an appropriate pro boxer so now
we can't tell because all the pro boxes
all the time say uh
many guys would beat him up easy you
know in boxing well here's your chance
you know sign up WB k FF sign a little
note and say hey I want to fight on your
organization I want to prove that boxing
that we have better hands than a mixed
martial artist and we team you up but it
makes martial art on the show
yeah but the mixed martial artists can't
use his elbows or his kick no I can't so
no but still you know the thing but the
mixed martial art is this that we
haven't physically in a better shape
listen I'm not taking anything away from
but I'm not saying anything these guys
are phenomenal I mean can't go to Olive
France for I'm not saying that it's an
unbelievable thing but once you are used
to kicking once you're used to kicking
and to grappling and the grappling
effect that is what gets you really
tired because every time when you crunch
ever when you to protect the takedown
you're working your core once you cross
that pumping up just like any other
muscle in the body well guess what's
behind your core your lungs and they
don't only pump up to the front but of
course the pump also inside so now your
lungs that normally go all the way in
you know if the core starts pumping
you can't go breathe in all the way
anymore because it's getting tight in
there because of the muscles around it
are getting tight so but once you are
used to that as a mixed martial artist
and suddenly like for instance if I say
- if I do type ads that is punching
kicking elbows knees everything right or
I do if I do several rounds for five
minutes of that or I do boxing I can do
I need a 14 rounds of boxing five
minutes I'll just fly through that if
I'm in the shape that I can do several
rounds of five minutes in Thai boxing
with the kicks that's how much the
difference is with the shape you just
get really tight that's what I always
would say but with boxers even when you
don't kick you know while you're boxing
on the bag on a heavy bag suddenly like
every thirty Seconds throw ten right
cakes as hard as you can that breaks the
beating breathing pattern you get really
tired and then you continue boxing again
it gets you in a way better shape
because what I realize is I didn't have
anybody to train with in Holland I had a
bag my first year of pancreas I pretty
much trained on the back two times a day
twelve rounds on the back that's what I
did 12 rounds for three minutes well if
you do that for three four months trades
you simply don't get tired anymore you
need to find things that get you tired
France is sprawling in between every 10
seconds defense you sprawl you get back
up and
continue breaks the the breathing
pattern the interruption and that's why
you're getting tired or they stand right
kicks and 10 left kicks and then
continue boxing again but you got to
come up with something because your body
is getting so used to it that you can't
really get really tired anymore so you
have to start adding the kicks and once
you do that you get tired again but
guess what you get tired you get used to
that then you start adding sprawls and
you know it's just an evolution but if
you take a guy who prepared himself for
a five-round fight in mixed martial arts
then you put him in a boxing event he
can go the entire distance and then
don't go tell me now all these people
are total weirdo call him McGregor Conor
McGregor also guesses out and MMA right
it asked the third round but that's what
I'm saying so so yes there is round
there were how they were three-minute
rounds yeah and you see him he did
Francis he started the gasps and bites
five but eight raunchy they're pretty
good several rounds against Mayweather
you see so that's what I'm saying it's
if he would have had a great stamina at
that time he would have gone the
distance I truly believe he would have
gone to distance with me about of ten
rounds only not 12 you know and that
would have been and actually I thought
it was already incredible what he did
you know he had pretty good boxing match
I thought when he was boxing against
Mayweather so but that don't build
stamina you can you know what we do is
like I have that workout right is the
boss with the workouts and mm and an
audio workout it's really hard to number
three workouts called the MMA
that's what sprawls so that is when I go
forward here the combination co-ceo
cross defense got a sprawl back up cross
your cross left to Christ rage right
side left hook right uppercut left you
guys defense he got a sprawl every time
sprawl sprawl sport and it gets you
really tired I had guys coming into my
gym we do five rounds of three minutes
of that as a warm-up with the sprawls
these guys they cannot even do the five
rounds and they will they will be
fighting it two or three weeks later and
they said how can you do this I said
that this is just the warm-up we didn't
even start the class but the thing is we
just start doing it and once you start
doing something you do it every day
within months it becomes normal you can
do it now the minute break we do
kettlebell swings we don't even take a
break anymore you know the schedule bell
swings in a minute a break and then we
go into the second fire now we got a
twenty minute five rounds of three
minutes with two minute break since
nineteen minutes and as a warm-up and we
had guys who had to fight two weeks
later they could not do the warmup
that's a warm-up it's a warm and a go
it's like what is this I say dudes we
didn't even start what do you do after
that climb mountains but let's part you
know my concept has always been very
simple I put myself I make myself tired
in the beginning of the training and
then the whole training I learn how to
deal with my power with less power and
still using technique because I'm you
know I tired myself but once you start
doing it like I said again for a couple
of months it becomes a little more and
that's suddenly you have to do something
else again to make it even more
everything you can get used to it's just
putting the work in
is that telling people you know people
it's always oh I can never do that no I
you want to lose a 30 or 40 pounds yeah
okay give yourself half a year you have
a so long half years nothing in the
lifetime it's a blink and it's gone but
if you have a race and you want to do it
in two and a half months now you're
really gonna force it and then
everything goes down the drain with the
diet you're already talking about it we
cannot eat this don't tell yourself you
cannot cannot I'm 100% with you never
you know oh gosh so you don't drink
anymore no I will never say that because
sometimes I drink a glass of wine with
it because if I don't do that you know
yeah I'm not gonna be a happy camper
anymore at least me other people that
might be different but at least it's me
you get used to everything just make it
a habit and just keep it on doing it and
you'll be amazed what you can do
so you cuz like I watched some fighters
over the year
in fact Conor's stamina this time
impressed me it was more yeah it was a
lot of grappling going on yes he
impressed him this time I thought he
would die a lot sooner but he impressed
me yeah but I even BJ Penn four years
yeah struggled with the stamina yeah I
thought it was maybe just a weakness
that some people have know can't build
on this stamina know what do this is and
okay 90% of the case I can never say a
hundred percent but I'm telling you that
they control what they're doing in the
ring in the gym if their coach says I
would you do three more rounds and they
don't feel like it they're not simply
not gonna do it because there are that
statue that the coach is not even gonna
say anything you see and that's the
problem
and once you're technically very good
and better than everybody else in the
gym you don't get tired because you
school these people what you need to do
is bring a few Pro boxers in or Pro kick
boxers who put the pressure on you and
watch how suddenly you get tired again
because its territory that you have
never been in the breathing pattern if
you have totally calmed me you can
breathe as good I could get fighters
tired by just fainting because they were
standing lights you know they start and
they get tired that breeze interrupts
the breathing pattern you know that's
why you get tired you need gas I did
I never tapped in class I mean I maybe
five times in the last 20 years I've
ever in enrolling so I knew that I was
pretty good there so what I did I did
only shark tank exercises because
otherwise I'm just working schools
around I school them and I don't get
tired so what I would do on 1 and 1/2
minutes with him 1 and a half on him
there was a shark tank I did why don't
happen it's Oleg Taktarov one and half
minute pedro hizo marker and marco who
was do those rounds six minute rounds
against the french guy every one and a
half minute that's a fun shark thing now
you're going to be Perez you trust me
you're gonna get tired but if I do this
with white bells I'm gonna get to hear
that's cool these guys and that's the
problem you need to bring people in who
can beat you who better who are better
than you and if you can't get those then
you have to do it like I do get yourself
tired another drill that I did I would
kick 2 minutes a kicking shield as hard
as I can 3 right 3 left 3 right 3 left
it started with the minutes because then
you're tired if you do this really hard
extremely hard kicking you're really
tired after a minute but again you're
doing it over and over again suddenly
becomes one and a half minutes and then
you get tired that's 2 minutes after 2
minutes I throw the shield down and lay
on my back they jump on top any position
they want and they start attacking I
start rolling rolling I roll only 2
minutes back
two minutes kicking full power now he's
got 2 minutes rest so every time when
I'm working and I'm getting more tired
he's taking a two minute break and now I
continue with him again you see so I
make him stronger and stronger and make
myself weaker and weaker but that's the
way you're gonna get in shape hill
sprints they could all do it on hill why
don't you do it in the treadmill that's
what I used to do treadmill you can't
fool the treadmill you can pace yourself
on hill sprints it's still good not
saying that but by the way I did it dirt
I would go run 11 12 miles an hour for
10 minutes that's the warm up then the
incline goes all the way up I go to 9
miles an hour and I say all the way up
when I was trading says 15 percent
because nowadays you have threatened
knows
Oh 30% so don't do that you know well
but again if you build it up you
probably can do it go slow
45 seconds on 30 seconds off 45 seconds
on again 30 seconds off that is a killer
that always got me really hard first
five six rounds easy but boy once you
start doing seven number eight number
nine dude you're getting or extremely
tired because the treadmill keeps going
9 miles an hour
you can't slow down you can't pace
yourself you got a keeper and I know
anyone running you know and I found a
lot of guys too with those seven miles
an hour eight miles now for somehow for
me it was I built it up like less lected
acid if I would do it at higher speed
otherwise I would do in a day too but
somehow nine was easier for me to do ten
eight miles now I don't know why it's
probably because of that you know you go
faster and you don't build up as much
like that I have no clue so but again
you could choose to it did you like the
treadmill contrast is just printing
forty years yes for anything never never
just straight I'm never like with my
knees right now I have bad knees right
now what I do treadmill I put it all the
way up and I walk with my leg stretched
because I have no cards on my kneecaps
so stretch legs is no problem for me I
can kick - I do these kicking drills do
now almost every once every day I tried
to work a pool workout I do and then I
do a kicking drill the kicking drill is
15 rounds of one minute so what you do
is your kick as hard as you can for one
minute you take one minute off and then
again one minute as hard as you can in a
moment of as one minute after six seven
rounds if you don't do this you cannot
do one minute anymore it's really hard
for you how long does a punching bag
last you I feel like you kick through
everybody knew at the gym I just pick
the ones out of the gym so I never know
when they go on when they break but
anyway what I do then if this is ten
weeks before a fight for instance right
so I did a normal workout and I'm gonna
do my half-hour workout - one minute one
minute now the one minute one minute I
do once I have 15 rounds the next week I
do one minute five seconds and I take 55
seconds so I add I increase the work
time is 5 seconds and take away 5
seconds of the rest time and then a week
later I go 5 seconds so anymore so
slowly but surely I do 1 minute 5 for a
minute 10 1 minutes 15 45 seconds rest
on minute 20 40 seconds rest till you
hit after like 10 weeks your
one and a half minute rounds full power
with 30 seconds break and people go like
well just you got to be in the best
shape of your life trust me because how
many times do you see a boxer or a kick
boxer they put somebody in the corner
and they unload for like 15 seconds 20
seconds and that gassing that's 20
seconds I'm doing a minute and a half
full blast 15 of those rods so it's just
training your body to throw out relax
relax and you just keep doing that
eventually you get used to it like
anything else in life and you can do it
I learn more from you and when I was in
[ __ ] one hour I get school now that
makes sense yeah make they call that
something right like they hit the
program there oh I don't know I intense
day one yes it's day one that was my
stamina I used you know what I had a
really cool I we would go at six o'clock
in the morning train because then there
was nobody in the weightlifting room we
take 50 of 12 exercises we do a power
training a pushing exercise a pulling
exercise
a conditioning exercise and then you
have 12 so 12 stations and then we go
around to 12 and it's you go 50 seconds
five zero seconds you give yourself ten
seconds to go to the next exercise
and then you do the exercise you the
whole route of 12 that's 12 minutes then
you take and you take a minute break and
then you do that circle you do three
times it's 36 minutes that's a very hard
workout as well because what happens you
stop pumping especially when you do abs
I get a challenge you do 100 apps I go
on a treadmill you're gonna die because
the ABS stop pumping up like I said and
it's not also pumping up on the inside
so now your lungs can not completely
inhale anymore that's why it's you know
with with the auto trainer that's why if
you do this this is proven by the ways
guys this I have this a medical problem
published medical journal so this one
represent proven if you do it two times
a day 30 repetitions in the morning and
in the evening if you do that for six
weeks after six weeks you can maintain
it by doing it once but if you do that
twice a day you take care of all the
like that acid in your core that you
have no clue what I will do for you that
will do so much wonders for you you can
shoot up EPO you can do ever that will
never do as much for you as if you take
care of the lected acid in your body
because that makes sure
that it doesn't start pumping anymore so
you'll constantly have have your long
ship have space in order to breathe
you're a [ __ ] genius right well tell
me ask my wife you just told us about
bare-knuckle boxing episode oh whatever
the peptides bat bites yeah the function
I love this I've loved this since day
one when I saw you on there with
somebody i order it right away and I
started the program from day one and I
even walk with it I made myself walk
with it around the park and they're
beginning I had to take it out because I
would get dizzy yep but then it just got
used to it yeah again when my I feel
that I'm smoking too much this is what I
[ __ ] use to clean out my I'll do this
in the morning you know we were just
talking about it and I love that because
I had the same thing if I'm ever having
phlegm right and I feel my lungs are but
I do 30 repetitions and listen not even
five minutes later you cough everything
out right it's so wild I and all my
friends have the same thing and what
does it call Oh to trainer no to trainer
do to trainer yeah you know go to
trainers comp there's a video on there
and you only literally and for me it
takes less than three and a half minutes
today I do 30 repetitions I have a
Facebook page it's a close one which
everybody can join and I will accept
them
it's bas Rutten so to bootcamp and you
will see me since last May I've been
posting videos I might have missed 10
because I've been traveling
internationally there's something but
that's it every single day I do a
time-lapse so they don't have to it they
can watch for 12 seconds or 15 seconds
instead of watching the whole frickin
thing for three and a half minutes
nobody's gonna do it anyway one thing at
least they can see that I do it because
if I do it hopefully I set the tone that
you say okay I'm gonna do it all so you
know it cured me of my asthma all my
friends cured me of their asthma nobody
is using an inhaler mir-1 now you go
over the website you read reviews from
people that are writing to me that I'm
off it boss it's officially I have no
more asthma my doctor said you know
those things are for me insane because I
made this invention when I was 14 years
old I was a severe asthma patients I was
a weakened about eight days in bed not
even able to eat because you couldn't
breathe
24/7 for eight days straight but then
after when I did that I would resume my
track and field when wide lungs would be
open again and once I would resume a
dragger field I will break my running
times and it drove me nuts I go why is
that every time after an attack I'm
running better until I saw a doctor I
saw a poster from a pair of lungs at the
doctor's office and you know as a kid
you think that there and as an adult
also that the affection is Nina lungs
right but it's not it's the air pipes
that go to the lungs those aren't
affected and and they get and there was
one open air pipe and next to it was a
pipe that was closed like this and that
was literally 14 years old I looked at
it I go oh man I've been working out my
lungs for eight days I've been pulling
in air through this little tiny hole
I've been I made my in spirit man
inhaling systems stronger and now when
suddenly the infection is gone it's much
easier for me to breathe oh I gotta come
up with something that controls the air
intake and I started experimenting with
like these coins from friends they had
coins we would go on vacation to France
coins with little holes in them and I
tried to put him in front of my teeth
you know so I could to only breathe
through that thing but yeah if you get
tired then you breathe in your mouth
door opens well your dad you know if
that thing goes into your lungs so high
but it's not always was in my head
constantly and then finally when I came
here and talked people always told you
know most people like that parties they
say I got an intervention I get this
invention disability when I would tell
my invention every single person will go
do you're gonna make that that that's it
that's so I eventually I said okay I'll
make it I started training with the
prototype now listen I carried an
inhaler with me everywhere I went
if I would come here without inhale and
I would sneeze like really finally I
sneeze three times completely closed my
lungs have time open them up within
there but it here oh so if I would
travel without an inhaler I would be
doomed
I always need every fight I had every
single fight ahead in my life in the
dressing room I have to spray my lungs
open because it's exercise-induced they
call it and like a lot of ask my
patients have it if they take a sprint
100-meter sprint they stop they're good
for about a minute boom lungs close up
then they need the inhaler to open it up
I trained with the prototype maybe two
and a half maximum three weeks I've
never used my inhaler anymore I don't
carry with me I don't have any
back not even as a backup thing in my
room nothing with me it's complete
freedom because these bulky things you
don't wanna have menu pants off
everywhere you go so I send it to a
friend of mine in Holland who had asthma
and I say he had tried this out you know
this is crazy at that time we used to
train with it instead of doing the
exercises and he called me a week later
he says I want to sell him in Europe
I said why he says my ass was gone I got
a week and then I started bringing it to
everybody with asthma and it was
freaking during their asthma I go man
we're on to something you know so now
I'm in Talk I have some really guy who
trains Usain Bolt you know and he throws
the trains three other gold medalists
from the last Olympics and the silver
medalist in boxing jet Mathias he's a
very smart guy scientist and he wrote a
really bad review about my competition
his product and my manager called me
said did you read the review I said
about what about that so-and-so product
and I said no but I can tell you that it
it sucked right the review and he says
how I said because they control the air
in and out I said it's another good
concept you only have to control the air
in because then you can completely
exhaling you're long she can empty your
lungs and entirely fill them back up
again but if you do with resistance
there's always air left in your lungs
right you cannot completely clean him
out so they all said that I was crazy
and now suddenly they want to partner up
with me because guess what I have the
patent but anyway I told the guy my
manager called a guy who wrote a review
if you can find out who that is I want
to send him a note to trainer and he
tells me you sure you want to do that
because what if they go to write a bad
review I said they're not because I know
it cured me four miles more all the
other people it's going to be good trust
me he finds the guy calls the guy says
hey I'm representing bas Rutten guys
answer right away
0:02 trainer we're already doing that
boom now I had suddenly 12 or 18
published medical journals because
they're already using that and whether
it's in 100% proven because that's what
it means if it's a published medical
journal that means it's 100% proven but
I always tell people if you know if this
is clinically tested don't buy that
product because if it was clinically
proven it would have said clinic improve
a clinic in testing doesn't mean
anything what was the result of the test
that's what you want to ask but people
nowadays they're so old school degree
touched it's got to be good because they
lead read the word clinically and they
think it
good no no if it's clinically tested
it's not a good product because if a
clinically tested and it was it would be
proven it would have said clinically
proven that's where you want to look for
and that's a promise Medical Journal
that's clinically proven and you can
find it you notice in our published
medical journals online you can
literally look in there and that's where
you can find the tests well I use it so
I'll need to read no [ __ ] tests there
you go you know saying I'm a believer
yes I'm like Ozzy Osbourne 81 I'm a
believer but you didn't need a bat
no [ __ ] that [ __ ] no this is uh I told
you I ordered it when I saw you on Rogan
I didn't even know who you were really I
know you were but I didn't even really
think about it and right away I felt it
I went up the ladder yeah I'm up to the
last hole and I sit there at night in
the mornings and when I'm doing things
I'll pop it in especially if I hear a
lot of wheezing yep if I hear a lot of
wheezing which the listeners hear yeah
and I work on that wheezing and yes it's
30 is the smoking pot there's nothing
you do yeah but this takes that top
layer of phlegm ah yep it really does
clean it out you know what I had a great
thinking but believes that right you
know believe video together yeah so what
happened when I watched myself with this
to stop breathing with my shoulders yeah
all that stuff I did I think you put me
in contact with her right yeah so I told
her that you guys had to get together so
I went over to the 5th Avenue where she
has her office right I'm coming in there
she says okay first thing we're gonna do
is measure his chest so I'm breathing
out and then she measured my chest she
says oh she's freaking out there you go
what he says no do it again do it again
that's not possible she does it again I
breathe in again and she goes or you
you're gonna have to wait then she runs
out and she comes back with another
doctor and I go okay what's going on she
said well if I wouldn't do this you
would never believe it
I said what's going on she says okay my
inhale normally when somebody breaks the
record so what they do they measure how
much your chest expands right because
that's how much air you can pull in
because that's how your lungs open up by
your chest expanding your lungs don't do
anything there's a vacuum between the
lungs and the body and if you expand
this that's how your lungs go open the
muscles almost don't do anything it's
all
your upper body doing it the more you
can expand the more air you can pull in
she says normally when somebody breaks
the record here it's like an eighth of
an inch maybe maybe maybe a quarter of
an inch you just broke it over almost
two and half inch
she says this is insane and the only
thing that I've been doing different
than everybody else she was was the auto
trainer so now she on a breathing
classes she gives everybody no two
trainer you know she says start
breathing with this so we have a really
good relationship now together because
she's focusing on the breathing out part
I'm focusing on the breathing in part
about I know I know people say yeah but
you cannot do it both because you just
said that no no you cannot do it
simultaneously you won't find a test
that's good yeah maybe a test written by
the person who invented that thing will
say it's good but a real test will not
say that but if you switch it it up if
you do one day you're inhaling and the
next day you do you're exhaling the way
she does with a balloon you know then
you strengthen both muscles and then
it's a really good combination to do so
it works both as long as you don't do it
simultaneous in with resistance that's
not gonna work from breathing to bed
knuckle beatings you're gonna watch a
show right away champ
what date is it it's a November 9 copy
it's a Friday night it's a friend and
I'll be in New York City doing two shows
but I will promise to tape it and give a
review of my own on the animalistic ways
I would love that I love all that [ __ ]
oh it's that fast man once I see blood I
start faint and I think the you ever see
one time oh you know don't tell me
there's no keep the phrases to yourself
that ring and it was covered with blood
I just went Wow when BJ Penn beat up Big
Daddy Stevenson yeah I was the most
blood ever in a ring Oh with the elbows
so one of the morning all the puddle was
there on the floor remember and I
remember being on the couch and they're
still waking up at like 4:00 in the
morning or what the [ __ ] Wow yeah I
can't compare yourself water just waking
up every few minutes unless you don't
know which a little needle she can even
use Annie
no I don't like needles I gotta look the
other way that I have an iPod on yeah I
listen to music gotta trust a lady yeah
I got a little lady down at Babbo she
knows exactly how to handle uncle Joey
they come in with the cart I looked the
other way the window how does he like
coming in and I know I'm safe yeah yeah
with no windows I get claustrophobic
okay I'll be really careful always a
pleasure brother yeah man always a place
thank you so much you always a pleasure
spread know the whole true trainer I
love it
you know it's helped me dramatically I
mean I'm not [ __ ] jumping over
windows yep I'm doing a lot better than
I was yeah man I'm so happy to hear that
all right to November night and then
what do you think after that it would be
a monthly card no I think in that
February they were kind of going for
that we're doing a lot of fun stuff good
stuff as well it's a very classy show
Jimmy Lennon jr. is gonna be the ring
announcer we got Kenny rice back with me
in the commentating booth I've worked
with him for such a long time like my
brother and I said we and he's got that
too old for you know Jimmy Lennon also
ladies and gentleman you know he's got
that Kenny little voice what I love
about him I was so excited that he he
was the voice for my last fight in 2006
and he was the announcer I go there's no
way Jimmy Lennon jr. so I called him and
he said sure boss you know for you I
will do anything so they came over Bert
Watson we have Bert Watson running
backstage all the stuff of crisis in
there yeah we you know microphone is
gonna come from the top down like the
old boxing we got the ring girls and
nightgowns we make it a very classy show
and then we let the boxing speak for
itself
you know because you know and it will be
bloody but our competition is their last
show for what I believe I believe that
14 fights there was one knockout and it
was one broken hands and there was some
little cuts there so CTE you I see I
hope people really don't believe what
I'm saying and Google it is bare-knuckle
boxing safer than boxing because then
you will find out that pretty much every
single test will tell you it's actually
safer because you hit the head less
heart so yeah do the homework come watch
the show 2995 man that's a monster right
that's nothing look you know so if you
want to hide that yeah that's going to
cost you $50 no no
I'm saying I mean not 3d glasses yeah
get the 2995 hit the 3d glasses at the
as long as the blood doesn't come out of
DV and you pass out you're fine I love
you brother I love you taking the time
and come along for that the church is
brought to you today by the ridge wallet
calm listen to me the ridge is a
minimalist front pocket wallet that
helps reevaluate you every day carry
launched by a father-son team funded by
Kickstarter in 2013 the ridge now
resides in the pockets of over a quarter
million men and women the RFID blocking
wallet is made by two metal plates
either titanium carbon fiber or aluminum
bound together by durable elastic band
let me tell you something this is the
coolest thing you'll ever see in your
life and for the first time I used it
last week when I travel you keep your ID
to ID cards in there it fit right in my
pocket it's not you know listen yeah I
like having a wallet in the pictures of
my daughter but when you travel you
don't need oh that's not what if it's a
plane goes dining oh look at the
pictures gonna change your [ __ ]
outcome no it's not
anyway I love this rich wallet the
ridges are minimal front pocket wallet
designed to ditch your bulky wallet its
slim it's and it's got a lifetime
guarantee it's the last wallet you'll
ever buy it comes in titanium carbon
fiber aluminum and over a dozen
different styles and colors what I'm
doing is this alright do me a favor I'm
gonna get your ten percent off with free
worldwide shipping by going to Ridge
Wallet calm that's rich wallet calm use
promo code Church CH you are CH okay
again Ridge wallet calm slash Church the
church is also brought to you by my
personal favorite audit calm these
people don't [ __ ] around okay they're
supplements a tip-top Magoo from the
Alpha brain to the [ __ ] is shroom tech
immune that which I test everyone's
every time I fly every time I fly
there's a bunch of people I'm not gonna
name no countries they come in there you
could tell they're bringing something
I'm not gonna name those countries I'm
not here to insult
I'm just here to spread the word with
you're gonna travel
immune Tek shroom tech immune is the way
to go you popped for those [ __ ]
things and a [ __ ] martini and not a
germ or get in your system you
understand me I don't recommend the
martini I'm just talking about the
[ __ ] four [ __ ] shroom Tex alpha
brain tremendous you having problems
remembering things you having problems
focus and pop two alpha brains you'll be
tip-top [ __ ] Magoo do you remember
the lyrics of songs you never even heard
before you understand me I can't help
you out with the way to the kettle bells
but as far as supplements are concerned
I got you you understand me so go to
honey calm right now
slash Church and get 10% off ready to
rock no drama no questions asked
you understand me I want to thank my man
I want to thank my man bas Rutten I want
to thank the [ __ ]
and I want to thank you guys for [ __ ]
supporting the church and for watching
this special don't forget next Thursday
sold out in its New York City but
there's still tickets available for
Friday and Saturday and the night before
Thanksgiving an Irvine there's a few
tickets left that's all I got for you
[ __ ] all right stay black have
a great weekend and I'll see you guys
it's Monday morning ready to rock
kick that [ __ ] melee